as tom brady put on his seventh super
bowl ring
many people began calling him the
greatest athlete of all time
but some feminists dispute that claim
they argue
that serena williams the tennis player
has won more championships
and therefore she is the greatest
athlete of all time
now i think it's ridiculous to compare
male and female
athletes to one another but even just
looking at the female athletes
have these people never heard of caitlyn
jenner caitlin's amazing
not only did she win the decathlon but
she even beat all the men doing it
did i say something wrong with regard to
serena williams and caitlyn jenner
did wha what did i say that was wrong
because i have been told time and time
and time again
i was just told this by the aclu we'll
get to it in a moment
that trans women are women i've just
been told by the biden administration
that trans women you know who maybe they
look like men maybe they have a bit of a
husky voice maybe they've got an adam's
apple and other
male appendages but very pronounced you
know
i won't get into it however they're
women that's what i've been told
so if that is the case then caitlyn
jenner is the greatest
female athlete of all time there's no
ques serena williams couldn't beat all
the men in the decathlon there's no
chance
now the left believes
they say that they believe that that men
can become women right that
trans women are women but none of them
believe that
we should call caitlyn jenner the
greatest athlete of all time and by the
way
you might you might say this is this is
one objection i've heard but only from
knuckle dragging conservatives
they say well no no caitlyn jeter didn't
win the decathlon bruce jenner won the
decathlon but now bruce jenner no longer
exists and bruce jenner's caitlyn jenner
no that's not what they believe go read
the wikipedia page read the arthur ashe
courage award
description that that caitlyn jenner won
they believe
the left and the transgender ideologues
believe that
bruce jenner never really existed bruce
was always caitlyn he was always a woman
trapped in a man's body and therefore
those accomplishments go to to bruce
now the reason i bring this up at all is
a democratic congressman very radical
guy from new york jamal bowman
listed trying to attack tom brady he
says
you know kind of forget about tom brady
the greatest athletes of all time are
one muhammad ali
two serena williams three tiger woods
um come again
number two is the big issue here i won't
take issue with muhammad ali or even
tiger woods at the moment but i will
take issue with
serena williams she's obviously not the
greatest athlete of all time because
men are better athletes than women
doesn't mean that that
women's tennis can't be an interesting
thing to watch especially when serena
williams is screaming at the referees
but it's just to say that the men are
stronger they're faster they're bigger
than women this is just a fact
we know that this is the case because
serena williams herself
in the late 1990s had a battle of the
sexes where she said she thought she
could beat a man who was ranked outside
the top two hundred
so very famously a player named carsten
brage
who was ranked i think 203 or 208
decided he would play serena williams
before their match he prepared by
playing a round of golf smoking a bunch
of cigarettes
and tossing back a few adult beverages
he then beat
one he actually played back-to-back
games with both williams sisters
he beat one of them six to one he beat
the next one six to two
it's just a fact of biology men men are
better
at sports uh we're not allowed to say
this though
even though now we're having these
debates about the the transgender
games and you have even many feminists
coming out and saying
wait a second these men who now identify
as women have an unfair advantage well
the aclu
is here to tell you that's completely
fake there is no advantage whatsoever
this is
the aclu of south dakota apparently not
the cleverest
aclu chapter they have an article out
debunking the myths
fueling anti-trans legislation
this because south dakota lawmakers are
trying to ban men from playing in
women's sports
uh so they have these these myths that
they're busting in these facts
myth the participation of trans athletes
hurts cis women
fact including trans athletes
will benefit everyone okay
um well what's the argument for that
it's kind of interesting too in this
article
they put the fact first because they
want you to read that top line so it
looks
it it's very confusing because it seems
that there there says that we're going
to debunk these things and they say
debunking including trans athletes will
benefit everyone it sounds like it's
kind of actually the opposite article
than it is
again more evidence that they're not the
brightest bulbs in the pack there
because their evidence is many who
oppose the inclusion of trans athletes
erroneously claimed
that allowing trans athletes to compete
will harm cisgender women
this divide and conquer tactic gets it
exactly wrong
excluding women who are trans hurts all
women it invites gender policing that
could subject any woman to invasive
tests
or accusations of being too masculine or
too good
at their sport to be a real woman
further this myth reinforces stereotypes
that those who identify as women are
weak and in need of protection
and then it kind of follows that down a
little bit too now
they're they're making they're kind of
highlighting all of these these talking
points these left-wing talking points
but it they never address the actual
claim which is
that the the trans athletes are
stronger faster bigger right and
therefore they'll beat the women
they never address that anywhere in the
debunking aspect
another one fact trans athletes do not
have an unfair advantage in sports
this is answering the myth according to
the aclu that trans athletes
physiological characteristics provide an
unfair advantage over cis athletes
now listen to their evidence here women
and girls who are trans face
discrimination and violence that makes
it difficult to remain in school
according to the u.s trans survey 22
percent of trans women
who were perceived as trans in school
were harassed so badly they had to leave
school because of it
another 10 were kicked out of school the
idea that women and girls have an
advantage
because they are trans ignores the
actual condition of their lives
that's not what we're talking about
nobody is saying
that the myth they're debunking is not
that men who identify as women
aren't bullied the myth they're
debunking allegedly
is that the men are physically stronger
they they don't even begin to address
that
the rest of the article goes on in
exactly the same way
it's very very strange to me
that anybody could possibly believe
this ideology
you know i gave a couple years ago when
this really was cropping up
i had a speaking tour and one of the
speeches on the tour was men or not
women
and other uncomfortable truths and i was
i was physically attacked
because i gave this speech and at the
time it didn't make sense but it's
starting to make sense to me
it's starting to make sense because
the the problem is well one you have to
not believe your own lying eyes right to
believe that like
billy you know who now goes by bethany
is uh not physically stronger than
an actual woman but the other reason is
because these two aspects of leftist
ideology
contradict one another on the one hand
the
the lg part of lgbt we're told
you are born with certain sexual
orientations and attractions
you can't change them right i'm born
this way no one would choose to be born
this way that was what they said in the
90s now they don't really say that
anymore
but uh you know because sex and sexual
orientation is immutable
therefore we ought to tolerate sort of
homosexual attractions and relationships
okay makes perfect sense to me
but then at the same time they say also
there's no such thing as sex there's no
such thing as gender
everything's changeable nothing is
immutable and men can actually become
women
he said well that doesn't make any sense
if there's no such thing as
immutable sex innate sex then
there is no such thing as l or g andrew
sullivan a gay guy
wrote an essay about this just a few
years ago
how on earth will we resolve this
problem
a lot of conservatives say that the
transgender activism is
is going to sort of finally awaken
many leftists to the incoherence of some
of their
ideology i don't think so anymore
i don't think that's true because i was
i was recently rereading george orwell
and and george orwell describes this
process exactly he says
at the heart of the regime the dystopian
regime that he's describing
is doublethink and what doublethink is
is the ability to hold two contradictory
ideas in your mind
at the same time right western
philosophy
is going all the way back to dear old
uncle aristotle
is based on the idea that you can't do
that or that or rather that
the you know a thing cannot be what it
is
and not what it is at the same time
non-contradiction
but double think in the dystopian regime
of george orwell
is this idea that actually a thing can
be one thing
and it's opposite or and something
different at the same time
and this is how they maintain power
because
what we are told by orwell is that if
you
have double think if you're holding two
contradictory ideas at the same time
then you are unwilling or un and unable
to think very deeply about a lot of
ideas
i think that is what the left is is
banking on
i i i don't think that
this contradiction is is a bug of
political correctness
or of leftism i think it's a feature
i think it is a way to undermine our
confidence in reason
or to undermine our confidence and
objective truth this is this is what the
left has been pushing for a long time do
you remember
when the smithsonian institution put out
a flyer
about a year or so ago saying that
rational thought and objective reality
is a characteristic of whiteness and we
need to get rid of it
and you're sort of an offensive flyer
that they put out
but it but it's all part and parcel of
the same
the same ideology i'm i'm no longer
confident
that uh leftism political correctness
locus whatever you want to call it
is going to undo itself on
on its own uh contradictions
because the contradictions are the point
we're still dealing in the realm of
logic but what what these kind of
ideologies are doing is trying to under
undermine
our confidence in reason and logic
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you